thousands of us are returning to the
skies
and we need aircraft technology to keep
us safe
but now us airlines say these cockpit
systems are at risk for mobile phone
signals
john sinclair spent years flying airbus
planes and now teaches budding pilots he
knows how serious the consequences could
be
especially in bad weather
the main concern here for the pilot is
he or she wouldn't be able to see the
runway and will rely on the plane's
automation to to perform the landing
now
if the altimeter is giving incorrect uh
readings getting the the information
wrong then they either might start
slowing down and try to perform the
landing too early or too late
one device is particularly at risk
that read out there is the altimeter
it's an absolutely vital part of the
cockpit setup it tells the pilots how
close the plane is to the ground as you
can imagine that's extremely important
to know but there are now concerns that
mobile phone signals from the ground can
interfere with that readout and that's
causing serious concerns for some
airlines
they're threatening to ground flights
potentially affecting thousands flying
to from and through the u.s while more
testing's carried out it's all to do
with the new super fast 5g network
clearly it's critical that these tests
are done but at the same time it's
critical that this this radio spectrum
is used for 5g that's adding a lot more
capacity into the mobile phone networks
which benefits everyone who uses a
mobile phone in the us which is everyone
so should we be worried in the uk
no say experts
america's 5g system is different to that
of other countries take france as an
example
their 5g power levels are around 630
watts in the us they're about two and a
half times stronger there are also
differences in the masts themselves in
countries like france the transmitters
are angled downwards away from planes in
the sky
not so in the u.s meaning more risk of
interference
u.s regulators are working with the
mobile phone companies and at t among
them has already said it will delay but
with some of the masters due to go live
as soon as tomorrow the runway's running
short to land on a new solution
jeff white sky news